[Music]
throughout history
our biggest leaps in technology have
occurred as a result of new materials
becoming available
i've shown you how it took humankind
centuries to master iron and steel
culminating in the explosion and growth
during the industrial revolution
how the accidental discovery of age
hardening allowed aluminium to take
humans into the stratosphere in droves
and how silicon forms the backbone of
this age of information
but today we're going to discover the
next great leap in material science
carbon fiber reinforced plastics carbon
fiber
and its even more futuristic brother
carbon nanotubes
have been touted as the next great
innovation that will allow humans to
build amazing structures that were once
unimaginable
elon musk recently revealed an enormous
carbon fiber reinforced plastic
cryogenic fuel tank
the largest fuel tank that has ever been
created for space flight
building spaceships of this size is not
an easy task
the larger the spaceship the more fuel
you need to escape the earth's gravity
the more fuel you need the bigger the
fuel tank needs to be to hold it
which just adds more mass to the rocket
carbon fiber reinforced plastics
provided a new way to keep the weight
down while maintaining the strength
needed to withstand the internal
pressures
but building a structure like this from
carbon fiber is no easy task
this is the sort of material that if a
crash landed on earth
just 70 years ago it would have been a
completely alien object
and we are still learning a lot about
its mechanics the fact spacex have
created a structure this size out of
carbon fiber reinforced plastics
that has already been tested at
two-thirds of its bursting pressure is
astounding by itself
but we've yet to see whether it can
resist the blistering cold temperatures
of the liquid fuels
without cracking and leaking and do it
repeatedly
after all the whole point of spacex
rockets is to be reusable
building a cryotank out of composite
materials is without a doubt the most
difficult part of building a spaceship
of this size
don't believe me listen to the man
himself say it this is really the
hardest part of the of the spaceship the
other pieces are
we we have a pretty good handle on but
this was the trickiest one so we want to
tackle it first
nevertheless the material will be
pivotal in reducing the weight of our
craft enough
to escape the gravity prison that has
kept humans as a single planet species
even though we are still learning a lot
about the material carbon fiber is by
themselves
are not as new as you may think the
first carbon fibers were produced by
thomas edison and joseph swann
for use as filaments in their new
electric incandescent lamps
the carbon fibers they created were
produced by carbonizing plant threads
like cotton
wood and bamboo this material did not
have the tensile strength of today's
carbon fibers
but they allowed edison and swan to
replace the expensive platinum filaments
being used earlier
the carbon bamboo filaments edison
developed lasted up to
200 hours and they were the norm for 10
years until
tungsten filaments replaced them not
much thought was put into carbon fiber
as a structural material
until the late 1950s when the union
carbide corporation
a company that manufactured light bulb
filaments began investigating
replacements for tungsten filaments
they started using rayon an artificial
cellulose-based material
poplar is a cheap alternative to silk
and cotton as the base ingredient for
carbon fibers
this was a breakthrough moment for the
start of the modern carbon fiber era
as the resulting material showed
potential as a structural material
researchers all over the world took
notice and just a month later the
japanese industrial research institute
began investigating how to make their
own fibers from polyacryl or nitrile
or pan for short the majority of today's
carbon fiber is produced with pan
even though it is an expensive byproduct
of oil production
it yields a fiber with a much higher
percentage of carbon than rayon
and it's easier to manufacture dr shindo
created long strands of this pan
material
which he stabilized by first heating it
to around 250 degrees
for up to two hours this rearranges the
chemical bonding to create a thermally
stable ladder bonding
these fibers were then heated again to
around 1000 degrees
in the absence of oxygen which expels
the non-carbon atoms in the material
leaving tightly bonded carbon atoms
arranged mostly in the direction of the
fiber
this material was both heat and chemical
resistant it had fantastic tensile
strength
and didn't rust specialized industries
like aerospace immediately saw its
potential to help spacecraft break the
grip of earth's gravity and when gay
brewer won the tahiyo
club masters golf tournament in 1972
using a carbon fiber composite shaft
the material captured the world's
attention to sporting goods
manufacturers all over the world began
creating carbon fiber products
golf clubs tennis racquets and racing
bikes started to be made with the
cheaper off-spec
fibers that the aerospace industry could
not use despite its high price
demand for the material kept growing and
by 1980 1 000 metric tons were being
produced a year
but it was still a notoriously difficult
material to work with
and manny still doubted its ability as a
structural material
during the development of the mclaren
mp4-1 one skeptical engineer is said to
have picked up a piece of carbon fiber
composite
just like this and easily snapped it in
half declaring that the material was too
weak and brittle to be used for the
ambitious carbon-fiber composite
monocoque
but he was breaking the material across
the fibers if he had attempted to break
it along the fibres
he would have had serious difficulty you
see carbon fiber is made from these tiny
thin fibers
this is a picture showing the size
difference between a carbon fiber and a
human hair
the carbon fiber is a smaller one these
tiny fibers by themselves can't be used
as a material
we first have to bind these long strands
of fiber together
with a plastic resin otherwise they're
just a flimsy fabric that can't hold
any load other than tension here you can
see a solid piece of carbon fiber
where the fibers are surrounded by white
resin but this technique causes some
problems for engineers when designing a
product with this material
because the plastic is weaker than the
fibers this is a unidirectional layer of
carbon fiber held together with resin if
we pull it this way
along the fibers it has fantastic
strength because the fibers are in the
same direction as the load
and thus can resist it but if we pull it
this way there is no continuous run of
fibers to resist the force
instead the resin matrix gets pulled
apart and the fibers add very little
strength to the material
to combat this engineers will layer the
fibers on top of each other
here we have a zero degree layer on top
of a 90 degree layer
so the material properties are the same
in those directions but now the 45
degree direction is weaker
we can keep adding more layers until we
have similar stiffness in all directions
but eventually the thickness of the
material will become too great
we reach another problem when we
remember there is nothing but the resin
matrix holding these layers together
and sometimes that fails and we get
delamination of the layers
this is why you often see the carbon
fibers woven into a fabric like this
but again woven fabrics can only be so
thick we also need to worry about the
drapability of the material
as these fabrics need to be shaped over
molds and a very thick material like
this
can make that job very difficult these
issues create a whole lot of work for
engineers working with composites
but with experience we have learned to
use these unique material
characteristics to our advantage
the designers of the mp4-1 managed to
create such a strong monocoque with the
material
that when the card did crash it silenced
many of its doubters
we can tailor the fiber directions to
optimize the material properties
here we perform the tensile tests on a
tiny piece of carbon fiber composite
with fibers only in the direction of the
force
creating an incredibly rigid structure
that barely deformed through the test
and managed to hold 5.3 tons before
braking
but stiffness like that is not always
desired for example
in the event of a crash you want your
car to crumble and deform to absorb as
much energy as possible and so composite
noses of f1 cows are designed to
fragment into
millions of tiny bits and this helps
absorb energy
and decelerate the care more slowly
pressure vessels like the dreamliner
fuselage are wrapped in layer after
layer of resin soaked carbon fiber
by a robot that places it in the exact
right position making the structure
perfect for withstanding internal
pressure
one of the big problems when building a
structure this big with composite
is that they need to be placed in an
autoclave to get the best quality
material
an autoclave applies heat and pressure
to the material
to set the resin and forces the air and
other voids that weaken the material
out of the resin during the curing
process the autoclave boeing uses for
the dreamliner is
massive and there isn't an autoclave in
the world big enough to fit the tank
spacex created
it's hard to know how they did it but
they almost certainly used an automated
tape placement robot like the one boeing
used to create their own smaller
cryotanks which can cure the resin with
a laser
as it lays the pre-preg carbon fiber
tape down but it's very hard to create
quality parts with this method as the
pressure of the autoclave is essential
for removing voids
in the resin and this is such a huge
concern for composite manufacturers the
parts are often scanned with ultrasound
technology to check that the resin has
cured with a tolerable amount of
microvoids
this machine sends ultrasound into the
part through a jet of water
and detects the voids in the material
these voids are an even bigger concern
for this application because the biggest
problem for the material
is cryogenic fuel leaking through micro
cracks and voids
looking at the outside of the tank i
would say with a fair bit of certainty
that the tank was made in two halves
that could fit in an autoclave
and was then riveted and welded together
which i would imagine will be removed
for the final version
as this just creates weakness in the
structure but this is all guesswork
breaking news yeah
so while i was making this video
pictures were posted to the spacex
subreddit by user deathcog
unit showing the remains of the cryotank
after being tested
it failed exactly where i said it was
going to fail but spacex have yet to
make a formal announcement about the
results of this new test
this does not mean failure of the
project we test things to learn more
and it's fantastic that spacex are
pushing the boundaries of what is
possible
i still have so many questions about how
this thing was made which just makes it
more frustrating that all the questions
being asked in the q a session after the
big reveal we're so stupid
this advancement if we can make it work
will be the most significant leap in
rocket technology we've seen in recent
memory
boeing stated that their cryotank
provided a 40 weight savings over
traditional aluminium fuel tanks
that is going to allow us to launch
larger vehicles into orbit reach further
into our solar system and hopefully
not in the too distant future it will
help humans become a multi-planetary
species
thanks for watching this episode is once
again brought to you by squarespace
who have helped me make my next move
with my website in my last video i
revealed i was working on building a
site that would continue my mission of
sharing the amazing engineering that
surrounds us in our daily lives
and this week i can announce that the
site is finally live at
www.realengineering.net
and it's looking great thanks to
squarespace squarespace allows you to
create a beautiful website or online
store with award-winning templates
they have 24 7 customer service and
their intuitive design platform makes it
easy to create the website you dreamed
of
you can make your next move with
squarespace 2 and build a beautiful
website by using the code
real engineering for 10 off your next
purchase thank you squarespace for
helping real engineering
exist both here on youtube and on our
beautiful new website
if you'd like to follow our progress as
we build this site please sign up to the
newsletter on the site
and thank you to all my viewers and
patreon supporters too i'm close to
making my first hire for this channel to
make more of the content that you love
if you'd like to support real
engineering please consider supporting
us
on patreon or maybe even buy the new
real engineering t-shirt
which is available as a 20 reward on
patreon or over on dftba.com
if you'd like to see more from me the
links for my patreon facebook
twitter and instagram accounts are in
the description